coup de projecteur enfin sur la caravane
sportive elle est de retour sur les
routes de Touraine jusqu'au 25 juillet
après Descartes blairés
Château-la-Vallière et Chinon en 2022
elle fait étape dans 6 nouvelles villes
de la Touraine sa mission faire bouger
les enfants et les initiés gratuites à
la diversité des disciplines sportives
Florent Clavel s'est rendue à
Sainte-Maure pour appréhender la
popularité de cette équipe
Armand 9 ans est un jeune sportif valide
si joue au tennis en fauteuil c'est par
choix celui de se mettre à la place
d'une personne handicapée pour mieux
comprendre ses difficultés pour
venir frapper la balle
antiténisme donc mais aussi soit la
perche judo football ou encore rugby cet
après-midi là la caravane sportive fait
étape sur les terrains de
Sainte-Maure-de-Touraine les enfants à
partir de 6 ans peuvent s'essayer
gratuitement à une quinzaine de sports
tous les niveaux se côtoient du débutant
au plus aguerri
bon c'est compliqué parce que j'ai pas
les chaussures déjà et sinon ça va c'est
sans bon terrain déjà organisé par le
Conseil départemental d'Indre-et-Loire
pour la troisième année consécutive
l'événement est aussi une vitrine pour
les fédérations notamment celle de rugby
à deux mois de la Coupe du monde en
France
on essaie de faire un maximum de
promotion d'en parler de les
sensibiliser sur toutes les dates donc
dès septembre à jusqu'à fin octobre et
puis et puis même il y a eu la Coupe du
Monde Féminine l'année dernière et là il
y a les moins de 20 là qui jouent en ce
moment donc on essaie de parler un peu
de tout ça la caravane sportive passe
cette année de 3 à 6 villes après
Sainte-Maure neuillez-pont-pierre
Montlouis-sur-Loire Langeais et enfin
Amboise qui clôturera la tournée les 24
et 25 juillet plus d'informations sur
touraine.fr